à l'approche du pont de Crimée des
centaines de voitures bloquées dans les
embouteillages certains décident même de
faire demi-tour
pourtant quelques heures plus tôt le
trafic a repris sur le pont mais une
seule voie est désormais praticable pour
l'ensemble des véhicules
on va observer le trafic si les gens
vont à Kertch à un appât ou dans
d'autres villes de la région de
Krasnodar on demandera à d'autres
personnes de les déposer avec leur
voiture pour les bus qui relient
plusieurs régions on les chargera sur un
ferry pour traverser le détroit 24
heures après l'immense explosion la
Russie cherche toujours les responsables
les experts dépêchés sur place pour
mener l'enquête évoque un attentat
organisé avec un camion piégé
sont identifié le véhicule et son
propriétaire il s'agit d'un habitant de
la région russe de Krasnodar une enquête
a été ouverte sur son lieu de résidence
pour l'heure Moscou se garde d'accuser
ouvertement l'Ukraine mais les partisans
du ligne dure dans la guerre exhorte le
Kremlin à répliquer il est temps de
combattre nous irons jusqu'au bout il
n'y a pas de retour en arrière possible
il est temps de répondre
la nouvelle aravit les habitants qui
posent ici devant un tableau du point en
flamme sans reconnaître aucune
implication le président wolody
mirzelenski lui a ironisé sur la
situation aujourd'hui c'est une bonne
journée en grande partie ensoleillée sur
notre territoire avec une température
d'environ 20 degrés malheureusement le
temps était plus nuageux en Crimée
selon les autorités prorus de la région
occupée de Kerson au sud de l'Ukraine
les réparations sur le pont de Crimée
pourrait prendre environ deux mois